[Music]
welcome back to our
never have i ever hour we're talking
about
first times and when it comes to eating
we all have certain foods
that we've never tried because they
freak us out
minus frog legs
our next guest is here to help us get
over our food fears
he is a chef on tick tock with more than
a million followers
please welcome my favorite 18 year old
social media superstar
and friend of the show eitan bernab
hello
i'm super excited to be here i can't
believe we're doing this in person
yes i'm excited uh let's get started
okay what was like the first food that
shocked you
okay it's gonna sound crazy i despise
bananas
i don't think bananas are terrible i
think i'm the issue i know the whole
world likes them
aton is the issue not bananas but yeah
well we invited some friends to try some
foods for the first time right here
on our show with us so let's meet one of
our friends from brooklyn new york
please welcome selena hi
hi selina all right hey guys
what fears are you facing today what
have you never eaten
so i am going to try spam for the first
time
have you ever tried something i have not
selena guess what etan and i have never
had spam either
okay good spam was actually invented in
1937 when there was a need
for non-perishable protein food items
and i mean it is meat in a can and the
name
spam people are unsure if it's the
acronym for spiced ham
or shoulders of pork and ham it is
pretty popular in hawaii
so some people do like it i'm excited to
see you try it selena are we
ready to do this ready
ready here we go i'm ready
it's okay okay
the texture is a little bit weird i feel
like if if we had like a steak of this
like a ham and eggs kind of feel the
work
that it's not the flavor the flavor is
okay it's actually fine
it's good it's just the texture and the
temperature
yeah tina are you still there
i'm still here we're gonna like somehow
we're gonna bring this back another time
like
in the near future and we're gonna cook
it and i think we're gonna have a very
different experience
i like that idea okay thank you selena
thank you for sharing your time with us
um
and um okay please welcome a mother
and an avid baker at zenobia
hello hi drew it's so great to meet you
you look fantastic thank you now xenobia
what food freaks you out sushi
what is it about sushi that makes you
know uh the main thing that it's raw
and i'm not really a fish person and
just to watch people eat it like some of
my family members they eat and i'm just
like disgusted
so you know can we cook this fish
well because but yeah what do you think
zenobia can we
try it i'll try it i'll try it all right
this i'm like actually excited about
oh god the clothes is going to fall no
no no thanks i thought it was delicious
can i give you a fun fact actually about
sushi yes eight times did you know
sushi was actually originally eaten as a
theater snack kind of like popcorn in
japan
it was easy to eat it was quick it was
with your hands and they ate it like
that a little fun fact do you see what's
it's on rice the rice actually was
originally just to give the fish an
umami flavor
and then it was discarded they just ate
the fish speaking of texture the next
one definitely has texture
oh god i'm so afraid cenopia
sorry i can't help you anymore today
because i'm still tasting fish
so i'm good it's time for
frog legs honestly it smells pretty good
okay
now actually a little fun fact about
frog legs
is frog legs were actually eaten by
monks
they actually voluntarily ate them
because they were able to classify them
as a fish and they had a no meat diet
and it was once just like a peasant's
food but now it's a delicacy for the
wealthy
and for drew maybe combination of both
i i feel very lucky right now
i feel like i just have to watch
i'm not gonna lie i'm really scared
[Applause]
this is fine this is great that's um
that's actually really
good all right and it was like a really
interesting
would you order it that's the question
um
probably not i was raised vegetarian so
like i'm a little meat
weary i love a good steak or like a
cheeseburger
i've ne there's so many things that like
i've never tried just because i was
raised in california vegetarian
um but once i ate a steak when i was 26
years old i crossed over to the dark
side and it's like every once in a while
i'm like i'm near the start
i feel you 100 super excited to be here
thank you so much for having me i love
being with you eton thank you
so much thank you zenobia thank you
selena and i'm so sorry selena
thank you eton always we'll see you like
so soon by the way you'll be right back
okay
thanks everybody
you